da quando non lo sa che c'è lo
smartphone quella tutti ragazzi e poi
minuti mi sono video sono fa vj ci sono
tra di suape lo so che in realtà ragazzi
oggi sarebbe dovuto uscire il momenti
epici bonus dei blog sono che ci ha
ripensato perché farne due attaccati non
è proprio una genialata quindi lo
metterò un po più avanti quando farete
bravo oggi non so perché c'è voglia di
fare cose a casa dopo il giorno di pausa
è andata di merda si può mai nella vita
bravissimo dai ma minchia la triste
storia di nuovo che non centrava il buco
è una cosa triste la sentire vero zio
guarda che [ __ ] non ci credo mai salita
ritenta o dai facciamo una roba militare
visto che saranno tutti tenerle armi sto
gioco pensatore da qualche posizione
proprio da intellettuale che pensa vero
zio perfetto ha finito ripensato sesta
camminata troppo gay cosa c'è in quella
canna zio roba pesante
ciao frate i tuoi genitori hanno anche
figli normali non lo so però ecco adesso
non più il bello è che una mitraglia una
spalla come se fosse un bazooka cazzo o
di un cestino alla merda non avrai la
mia merda zio nuti a che corto è
riuscito anche a fotter meno la mer
guardali come ci sguazza fiero
scusate ragazzi non volevo madonna che
laghi rimasti in casa contro facciamo
questo guarda che vinco perfetto mi
prendi per il culo frate no sì o no
ma allora sei stronzo dai dai ragazzi
per i 2 milioni ad occhi chiusi a caso
[Musica]
ok do ad abu dhabi li devo farlo
assolutamente fatemi capire
ok stiamo scherzando
soppressi chimica che presa ti è
piaciuto il tavolo non fatemi ma è
bellissimo
oh mio dio come li farei questo ma che
cazzo è mica è morto la ragazza non li
farò in eterno sto coso è fantastico
stai vendendo quel coltello non infila
nel culo
guarda che scherzavo ed io non è che
steve vabbè ma che non ci crederai anno
sto capendo una mazzata uno che se ne
esce col coltello l'altro che tira
lascia a strozzo sei stato non ne ho
idea cosa merda un bio step ciò brewster
sono quasi stato schiacciato da un virus
del formato gigante ragazzi questo è il
livello della vita non ho letto cosa mi
ha scritto e rotti i [ __ ] per la
merda no no no scherzavo scherza ma
perché lanciano i coltelli cosa c'erano
quei coltelli sto livello barra pa pa pa
pa pa pa pa no ma che posso scacco
l'army senza chemical chi cazzo vuoi
perché si è vestito come andrà di pregio
file schiacciati cura ma che fino adesso
li vede stai cucinando zio e il boss di
è primis ma seriamente devo batterlo ma
chi è affatto o mio dio ho giocato a
blog board posso battere il suo schifo
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no c'ho fatto ci ho
fatto ho schivato perfetto madonna
battuto il boss abbattuto arbosti è più
il che cosa troppo epica non ho mai
visto un livello così bello in è più se
la prima volta è stato troppo figo visto
tutto ma cazzo hai fatto vedere sei una
palla di merda
vergine
nate horse perfetto stavo scherzando
cosa vuoi non lo faccio un partito a
casa calmi che possiamo fare devo
scappare la qual cosa non ho capito
cos'è ma c'è gente io io io devo
arrivare prima perché c'è gente che
vuole mi fate giocare un livello decente
senza che non capito neanche arriva
anche gesù chiedo e non si sa ma droghe
c'è un livello che si chiama droghe come
ha fatto a diventare così swag non vuoi
provare un po di droga no no no le
droghe fama va a getto figlia ok
prendino un po ma come un casco dei daft
punk quando piquet da abbiamo preso
della droga che cazzo est olivero ancora
certo ma qual è il senso di questa cosa
nella vita perché c'è una lumaca ma chi
è che la stessa o scassato un fungo cosa
sono
oh mio dio da adesso in avanti avrà gli
incubi a vita ma quanto a 2 la nostra
trapanatura l'effetto liste droghe ma
eccoli lo accecato devo riconoscere
comunque ragazzi che è una figata e
questo sì però borchiato non voglio
sapere che cosa cazzo appena giocato che
va bene così hai mai mai mai mai mai mai
rossi c'è rossi c'è rossi c'è rossi c'è
rossi certo continuando a guida come
come faccia muovere le braccia non ce
l'ho attaccato al corpo
non ci credo si è scassata l'amici io
sono vivo quando mai nella vita
ma alcuni terol cazzola noi hanno
rifatto di nuovo e bellissimo questo
richiamo la che roba persona era geniale
per niente dove sopravviverà a caduta di
balconi ma lo ricordo ancora cazzo che
figata dato non ho mai capito perché non
muoio c'è impossibile come faccio a
esser vivo dopo una caduta così com'è
possibile addio
ma c'è un finale sto gioco appartenente
non faccio più domande tranquillo io
scelgo te cos'è stata e vabbè prenditi
la mia gamba figliolo fanno buon uso
rotto stronzo manderò qualcuna ucciderti
ecco ci pensa alla vicina
non c'è nessuno che mi rimane vice ecco
la mia gamba l'unica amica che operano
ragazzi siccome voglio vedere se riesco
a fare dei quiz decenti su di me ma che
cosa devi provare a vedere che cosa esce
fuori diciamo favi jenkins due come
prima giusto per curiosità non so qual è
il vero nome di fa vj lorenzo la la pata
certo è che io conosco troppe persone
che si chiamano la patata con i must in
casa ma come dava [ __ ]
ecco la fanciulla vj alix cosa cazzo di
scrittori fa vj a xbox
le risposte sono sì certo in realtà non
c'era l'xbox però sono costretto a
rispondere sì va bene a famiglia il
piace barbie ovvio che cazzo ne so io
che quanto 6 simplicio
bene ho fatto credo di aver giocato il
livello della vita ragazze nella quarta
puntata di just dance la gamba di fa vj
e pelosa o sexy gare dopo la ceretta col
cazzo sexy zio a non pelosa perfetta in
quell'episodio di outlast incontra
l'uomo mangia hamburger
ecco terzo terzo il terzo grande conosco
bene i video che faccio fantastica
complimenti complimenti non complimenti
fa vj se il migliore grazie zia perché
mai ragazzi io e voi siamo interconnessi
abbiamo sappia pensiamo alle stesse cose
a cosa sto pensando di dall alta voce
che bello che tu stai in silenzio io sto
a guardarti potremmo passare per di due
ed efficienti ecco ragazzi concludo che
l'episodio è stato etico perché abbiamo
fatto dei livelli che non ho mai fatto
una mia vita coltelli a parte i ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto concludo che
episodi di aprile ci vediamo in un
prossimo video o di host i capelli come
se i ragazzi sia il video è piaciuto
questo documento è un mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e condivido tra
prescrizioni sa inserirsi discreti ci
diamo subito bella ragazza